en guyane le père noël s'est déjà mise
en route mais point de traîneaux cette
année le père noël du fleuve descend le
maroni sur sa pirogue créant
l'étonnement parmi les enfants sur le
fleuve maroni
le père noël a troqué ses vannes et son
traîneau contre une pirogue motorisée un
moyen de locomotion bien plus adapté que
l'attelage du grand nord ni barbe
blanche ni habits rouges fourré c'est le
père noël du fleuve
accompagné de ses danseuses et comme son
compère barbu il est très attendu
le père noël du fleur n'a pas de vote et
donc point de jouets par milliers
mais il a ses secrets ceux de la forêt
de la presse traditionnelle de la canne
à sucre secret qu'il se doit de
transmettre aux nouvelles générations en
cette période de noël noël ubeda qui
pour les bushinengué c'est cadeau il a
paniqué
pour la bouche on la gagne même pas des
fans s'est fait des surprises
on voulait créer un père noël noir qui
amènent des cadeaux du fleuve offert
semblabes alors pour remercier le père
noël du fleuve on danse on chante un
hommage à sa venue
lui qui a tout le maroni à descendre sur
sa pirogue est encore dans d'autres
villages à visiter